is it time
it's in a it's not Theory time it's big
announcement time time time time time so
for the last couple of months I've been
working really really hard on something
behind the scenes I'm so excited to
launch it today and I think you guys are
gonna love it just as much as I do I've
come up with a whole new way to sell out
and make loads more money but this will
hopefully help you support the channel
and get some some cool merch out of it
now as you know I've just had twins I'm
constantly looking for ways to feed them
until they can grow to the point I can
exploit them for this channel as editors
and because of that had to come up with
some creative ideas with some different
YouTubers that you might not expect us
to work with now it might surprise you
to know that me and Ryan Arie were
actually quite good friends don't tell
anyone I said that and there's also Greg
from Little rejects who I speak to quite
a lot and you know basically the
conversations I have with them and them
going oh Paul you're so much better than
us your videos they're amazing they
should be on TV so I've wanted to give
something back to them and you guys as
well and I've come up yes it was me I've
come with this idea that we should
basically do a joint merch store that
pulls all Our Brands together and it's
just one outlet that you can support
every single Channel even if you don't
like mine you can go support Ryan you
can go support Greg this place is called
Zero edition shop zeroedition.com and
it's basically it's beyond just your
generic nerdy stuff there's Custom
Designs lots of in-jokes and this will
make you really stand out in the nerdy
crowd I know you guys you want to see
how Niche and nerdy You Are by having
screen Crush sayings on your on your
t-shirts but you definitely want a
theory time one and we've also got some
amazing heavy spoilers designs on there
as well now I love spoiling and I want
you to spoil yourself so I'm going to
give you some of the biggest spoilers in
history on specially custom-made
t-shirts not only do these allow you to
celebrate some of the greatest moments
in cinema but they also allow you to
spoil anyone who's decades behind the
rest of us I absolutely love this Mori
Darth Vader TV show that we've just
launched and we've also got a spoiler
man one with The Sixth Sense yes we're
getting very creative with the spoilers
here as you can see yeah that's me as
Superman spoiling The Sixth Sense for
everyone and you know what I quite like
this t-shirt what's different to just
the regular mid shelf as well is that
these are very high quality clothing the
things I would actually wear and we've
designed them to basically make you look
your best at all times they accentuate
the arms shoulders upper part of your
chest but they don't accentuate your
mid-rift so you know the hang of you
really really nicely this is absolutely
the best way to support the channel and
you know with it being from me I'm gonna
love it if you guys give your input as
well and we can all kind of just build
this nerdy Community around heavy
spoilers I basically need you guys to
come with good ideas so that I can beat
Ryan's good ideas and Greg's good ideas
as well but saying that I want to thank
those guys as I couldn't have done it
without real rejects or screen crush or
shop zeroedition.com anyway I really
can't wait to see what the future holds
with Zero edition and if you want to
check that out the links in the
description all got the shop0edition.com
thank you very much I really appreciate
it take care peace